la question centrale que l'on se pose on
en a parlé depuis le début de ce journal
at-on le moyen d'un déconfinement si la
date du 11 mai dans tous les esprits
elle est aussi l objet de toutes les
inquiétudes est de tous les doutes
tentons jugés trop proches tantôt jugées
trop tardives les conditions d'un
déconfinement partir du 11 mai seront
elles bien réunis c'est l'objet de notre
face à face et pour en débattre nous
sommes nous en direct par skype avec
benjamin amar enseignants en porte
parole cgt val-de-marne bonsoir benjamin
amar côté en face à philippe merlant
economis essayiste bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous aussi à distance philippe
herlin dans quinze jours le grand plan
un suspense que tout le monde attend
sera dévoilé vous y croyez benjamin on
vous a déjà entendu pousser des coups de
gueule sur ce plateau vous l'attendez
avec fébrilité ce plan du gouvernement
ah non vous savez un cégétiste si jamais
fébrile non moi je vais vous dire je moi
je suis quelqu'un qui résonne simplement
moi ce que j'attends ce qui est pour moi
la condition sinequanone de cette
histoire de déconfinement c'est les
conditions de sécurité sanitaire voilà
les masques les masques et notamment on
le sait très bien
on nous a dit le gouvernement nous a
seriné pendant des mois en dix ans dans
ce qui était un mensonge éhonté
il n'y a pas besoin des masques ça ne
sert à rien on sait aujourd'hui c'est
totalement faux que c'est porter un
masque setra gestes barrières
extrêmement efficace donc se pose celle
qui est sûr là c'est à dire que
l'urgence économique moi je la comprends
et je la partage
bien évidemment que l'économie ne peut
pas rester au point mort ainsi pendant
des mois
quoique reconnaissons qu'il ya beaucoup
de secteurs de l'économie qui continue à
tourner et des secteurs qui ne sont pas
essentiels mais mais pour autant le fait
que l'on reprenne une activité
économique normale bien évidemment mais
comme l'a dit philippe martinez par la
peur au ventre
il faut effectivement des séquelles la
première des exigences c'est la vie des
gens c'est tout simplement le fait que
les gens ne risquent pas leur peau voilà
et donc cette question là moi j'ai
écouté le
gouvernement la conférence de presse de
monsieur philippe et c'est encore le
flou la bombarde et le pipeau parce que
finalement depuis des mois les masques
arrive
écoutez on les attend comme le messie
donc c c'est tout simplement ridicule et
je pense que c'est la question
essentielle si on a effectivement des
conditions de sécurité sanitaire le
déconfinement pourra se faire
sereinement
si ça n'est pas le cas on n'en verra pas
les gens au casse-pipe
philippe herlin on envoie les gens au
casse pipe c'est clairement la crainte
de benjamin masque c'est la vôtre
également oui c'est possible un passant
que la politique du gouvernement et est
dirigée par la pénurie alors que moi je
considère que le 11 mai c'est une date
qui est bien trop tardive
il faut savoir que la france est le
dernier pays en europe à des confiné et
ça veut dire que nous allons prendre la
retard sur tous les autres concurrents
européens
et ça veut dire aussi que de nombreuses
entreprises françaises vont envoyer tout
à l'heure le chef alléno parler des 40 %
des restaurants qui n'auront pourrait
pas ouvrir éventuellement après le
confinement à 40% en faillite ce sont
des centaines des milliers d'emplois et
est donc pas je considère qu'il ait eu
plusieurs gens d'ouvrir les entreprises
que les écoles parce que le problème des
écoles c'est que comme on a affaire à
des enfants il est pas forcément facile
me faire respecter les règles de
distanciation sociale alors qu'avec les
commerces les restaurants les coiffeurs
les fleuristes et cetera
on a affaire à des adultes donc il est
quand même plus simple de faire
respecter les règles de distanciation
social les gens font la queue à
l'extérieur et c est donc pour moi il
faudrait faire mettre la priorité sur
les entreprises et avant le 11 mai et
les écoles
ensuite une fois qu'on aura pu mesurer
qu'il n'y a pas de retour de l'épidémie
en france sauf qu'il ya peut-être un
petit problème pratique c'est que en
général quand on a des enfants la maison
c'est un petit peu compliqué de se
rendre au travail n'est ce pas
c'est ça peut-être l'arrière français
benjamin hammam a bien évidemment bien
évidemment enfin personne ne peut être
naïve dans cette histoire on le sait
très bien
moi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le lire
or vous savez le le medef c'est l'acteur
furtif de la vie politique française
c'est à dire que lyon personne n'en
parle mais il est là il est bien là
croyez le bien
et donc le medef il fait le patronat
cette pression sur le gouvernement
et vous l'avez très bien résumé
et pour cause d'activité économique
repas il faut que les gosses
effectivement que les élèves soient
gardés qu'il soit dans les écoles dans
les collèges et et dans les lycées et si
on fait des comparatifs européen alors
il faut tout dire et il faut expliquer
que en allemagne alors en espagne en
italie dans l'état de new york
la rentrée scolaire elle est soit en
septembre soit reportée sine et didier
c'est à dire remporter jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
benjamin labbé norvège au danemark et on
allemagne et on rouvre avant un
pardonnez moi l'allemagne est
progressivement donc que ces pays là
sont des pays où l'épidémie a eu une
importance bien moindre qu'en france par
contre en espagne en italie dans l'état
de new york c'est à dire dans les
principaux foyers de l'épidémie
c'est en septembre voilà et ce à un
certain se garde bien de le dire
alors après dans les entreprises mais
écoutez je vais vous dire encore une
fois se pose la question de la sécurité
sanitaire
parce que ce qui est valable pour les
profs est valable pour les salariés du
privé
bien évidemment et ça c'est un vrai
problème parce que quand on va dire aux
gens moi je vais vous dire en tant que
sais-je et issus souvent interpellé y
compris par des messages sur les réseaux
sociaux ou par des mails par des coups
de téléphone etc de salariés qui me
disent ben moi dans ma boîte j'ai la
direction qui vient de voir et qui me
dit que j'ai intérêt à le pointer et
quand je leur dis qu'il n'ya pas de
masque ils disent ils mais il exige de
moi que je vienne et ils exigent en
portent en eux mêmes des masques et des
gants
donc encore une fois la sécurité
sanitaire ça doit être l'alpha et
l'oméga sur cette question là que
l'activité économique reprenne mais
écoutez très bien avec des conditions
sanitaires
on a énormément de cas de salariés qui
ont été contaminés sur leur lieu de
travail
voilà nous on a des cas la cgt on les
ressent sont les connaît et donc
attention s'il ya une deuxième bague qui
arrive on connaît pas grand chose sur
cette épidémie on marche comme des
aveugles et on tâtonne si elle arrive
et bah qu'est ce qui se passera certains
prendront des airs de pleureuse mais ce
sera trop tard
gouverner c'est anticiper et donc
certains sont en réalité se comportent
comme des apprentis sorciers donc nous
on a l'air tonti attention cette maladie
est un fléau c'est une véritable peste
attention la sécurité des gens c'est le
premier des critères ans philippe herlin
quelle est leur garde l'économiste que
vous êtes sur l'exception suédoise qui
se portent pas spécialement plus mal que
la france au que les autres pays un le
bilan n'est pas brillant mais enfin
c'est pas pire qui a choisi quand même
de sauvegarder l'économie de crainte que
ça fasse finalement entre guillemets
plus de morts après ouais mais ce qui
s'est passé en suède c'est que les
règles' sensation sociales ont été
respectées de façon très importante donc
il n'y a pas eu d'explosion
et puis c'est des pays où comme en
allemagne ou de pays du nord il ya eu
des tests nombreux et une prise en
charge par la parole par l'opie par les
appareils de santé et rapide ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la france voilà le
problème de la france c'est qu'on n'a
pas assez de basques et moi je mettrai
ça aussi sur le dos d'un certain
étatisme français parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'au jour ils ont des douanes
qui le montrent que si vous voulez
apporter plus de 5 millions de masques
en france vous pouvez faire l'objet
d'une réquisition on décourage les
entreprises ou les vendeurs ou n'importe
qui d'apporter une masque pour risque de
se faire à questionner quoi il ya
beaucoup de pharmaciens qui pourrait
vendre qui pourrait acheter importer des
masses et les vendre au public et qui ne
le sera au genre parce que l'état a
redit on est dans un modèle étatiste et
dirigiste en france moi je considère que
pour qu'on puisse avoir des tests et des
masques il faudra libéraliser le secteur
c'est alors qu'il faut permettre à
n'importe qui alors en premier aux
pharmacies qui qui qui ont déjà leurs
réseaux mais à n'importe quelle grande
surface magasin de pouvoir commander des
mâts à ce que ce soit fabriqué emporté
de l'étranger et de les vendre et de
cette façon là on pourra avoir
suffisamment de masques alors
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde se repose
sur les méga commande que qu'a fait
l'état et on est obligé de le croire sur
parole le problème c'est que si le 11
mai il n'ya pas le milliard ou les 2
milliard de masques la question qu'on
peut se poser
vu de l'extérieur mais c'est peut-être
pour ça c'est peut-être plus compliqué
que ça enfin l'une des clés du succès
allemand c'est d'avoir réquisitionné
plusieurs
jean et d'un forfait la fabriquer des
masques en nombre alors c'est vrai que
pourquoi on l'a pas fait peut-être que
vous le savez mieux que moi mais en
l'occurrence moi je me porte en faux
vis-à-vis de style empire monsieur-là
correspond à une petite musique qu'on
entend ces derniers temps certains ont
effectivement le comment dire
l'inventivité de pod comment dire de 2 2
m dans le box des accusés
le soi-disant étatisme ou le trop grand
poids de l'administration
mais attendez sur cette histoire de
masques c'est très simple qui est le
responsable
si ce n'est effectivement le libéralisme
qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils sont les
responsables si ce nom si ce n'est
effectivement les délocalisations qui
ont été commandés reporter je dirais aux
au pinacle par certains il certains ont
fait de la délocalisation une sorte de
fantôme une fatalité
alors qu'en réalité effectivement
d'autres pays ont conservé leur
patrimoine industriel ont refusé de le
brader
elles sont en capacité de produire des
masques la france est la sixième
puissance économique mondiale est les
grands principes à une des des
principales nations économique
mais le roi est nu puisque nous sommes
un foutu de produire des masques et et
que nous avons sur ce secteur là mais
comme sur d'autres brader notre
patrimoine industriel
je vais vous dire lors et le jour
d'après je lis j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire mais j'aime le marteler le
jour d'après doit être celui dans lequel
nous mettons effectivement la
mondialisation dans le box des accusés
cette crise cette crise du coc vide 19 à
tous les égards est une crise de la
civilisation libérale un philippe herlin
la réponse non mais et il faut être
sérieux c'est pas l'ultra libéralisme
est la cause de ça la france c'est le
pays le fait d eux qu a le taux auquel
le taux de prélèvements obligatoires le
plus élevé donc ça décourage la
production en france donc la meilleure
façon de faire revenir la production en
france c'est de diminuer le niveau des
taxes et des impôts et en heure a dû le
faire depuis longtemps
c'est aussi de lutter contre l'esprit
normatif et bureaucratique dont la
france est une des championnes du monde
et puis c'est aussi d'avoir des
syndicats qui sont plus responsables en
allemagne les syndicats discutent en
france la cgt fait
ce poids pour un non on le voit par une
pour les dockers et où il ya des pertes
d'emploi où la plupart du trafic se fait
à gênes ou dans d'autres ou dans
d'autres ports et le et tous les tous
les ports français perdus perdre de
l'acidité et ça se resserre attentes et
surtout le secteur économique
doc stoxx donc c'est assez voilà qu'il
faut agir c'est une baisse des impôts
une baisse de la bureaucratie une baisse
des normes et un dialogue social qui
soit facilitée par rapport à aujourd'hui
voilà et c'est à ces conditions là qu'on
pourra faire revenir les usines en
france
et effectivement c'est un objectif que
l'on doit se fixer dès la sortie du
confinement pour avoir une reprise la
plus vigoureuse possible merci à tous
les deux vous mettra pas d'accord ce
soir benjamin marin merci philippe
herlin d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
face à face persia vous